[Music]
waterl let's go out to a water and talk
to Alyssa not Napoleon what's up
Alyssa hello Dr John how are you I'm I'm
doing good I'm happy to be on your show
I'm happy that you're on the show what's
up oh okay well I'm questioning myself
okay am I enabling or am I being truly a
supportive
partner um tell me what's going on with
okay so I've been with my boyfriend for
over three years and the last couple
years I feel like our relationship has
pretty much
plateaued when I do bring this up to his
attention I feel like he weaponizes his
sobriety against
me he goes into telling me stories about
his past life and reminds me how much he
has changed since he has stopped
drinking and um I am truly proud of him
I see the work he has put into his
recovery he has done 180 as a
person yet I come from a family of
recovering addicts myself and I
understand it's not a walk in the
park and I I I'm kind of questioning if
I I'm staying with them because I I'm
kind of used to used to that environment
or I'm I'm just kind of confused right
now yeah yeah you've got a lot on your
plate don't
you yeah I can I can hear it in you um
so let's move sobriety off the table
okay well let me ask you one question
how long has you been
sober uh he's been sober for over three
years okay perfect so let's move that
off the table four four I'm sorry four
let's move it off to the side okay okay
Have you communicated to your boyfriend
what you need in your relationship
yes I have okay and just I want to do a
quick rapid fires okay okay and he has
told you through roundabout stories
about his past that he doesn't really
care what you need right now you should
just be proud of him for how far he has
come since uh 48 months
ago pretty much that's how I feel okay I
want you to live in that context for a
minute because that will inform your
next question which I think you're on to
something I'm very very very I mean just
astoundingly proud of him for getting
sober big
time in four years
later yall should have been well into
maybe round two or round three of
building a new
relationship and you're not you use some
language when you first started talking
which is our relationship has plateaued
I don't like that language because it
externalizes relationship the language I
like to use is one or both of us have
quit working on
this because the relationship in of
itself doesn't do its own thing like
people say well this relationship ran
its course that's bull crap we quit
working on it right and so it's often
easier to distance ourself from the work
that is marriage that is long-term
relationships friendships employment
relationships it's easy to set it over
there and put it at arms length instead
of saying no one or both of us quit quit
trying and what I'm hearing you say and
obviously this is just one side of the
conversation is that you stood by him or
he got sober and you probably picked up
a lot of slack didn't you yes and you
probably were stuck somewhere in the
fourth or fifth ring of Hell prior to
him getting sober
right um we got together after he got
sober okay so all right so you missed
that part which is excellent so you
carried you carried a lot of the
water and then he just wants a pat on
the head and wants to be able to do
whatever he wants to do moving forward
is that
right I I believe I mean yes and no um
help me
out I mean he does turn to me a lot and
ask me a lot of questions and this is
where I get a little to the point where
I'm questioning things um it's as if he
turns to me to be his conscience for
him if that makes any sense whatsoever
not really give me give me an
example um any kind a time he he faces
any kind of conflict or situation or
whatever he he always comes to me and
discusses it opening with me and um the
way he interprets everything is
in my mind not um remotely even close to
what the actual situation
is and I I sit there and I digest it and
just let him keep talking to me and then
when he's done I kind of talk him
through with how I see the perspective
of things and then usually a day or two
later he comes back and he's like yes
you were right about that so that sounds
incredible to me what's the problem with
that I just I
just I just feel like there's always
chaos I yet there's not actual there's
there's a lot it's chaotic give me an
example walk me through it be pretty be
very specific be pretty specific with
me
well oh I don't even know where to begin
all right let me let me back out let me
back out a little bit further okay do
you not want to be in relationship with
him anymore because if you don't that's
okay or maybe you want to want
to I just I just feel like I'm getting
kind of my needs aren't getting met
because I'm constantly having to
meet his needs okay there we go I don't
know I don't know if he can
actually meet my needs because he
struggles tell me tell tell me a few of
the needs you've asked him to
meet
just
to to listen and to to
um you know if if I if I'm looking at an
important decision making of any sorts
whatsoever um I I ask him and he kind of
just shuts down he doesn't that's your
life you you deal with that you know I I
I
don't I don't want to you know that's
that's not me and so then I'm stuck
doing it alone anyway you know and it
just um I
just really want that
companionship with him to be able to
kind of balance each other out
okay I I 100% agree with
you I think the challenge here is for
you to be in a non it's going to feel un
Hollywood and it's going to feel UNR
rantic but I want you to take some time
to be really specific about what that
means to
you
because if you're the smartest most
caring person he
knows and you ask Kim hey what do you
think about this situation I'm dealing
with it may be that he's a coward and a
wimp and is self-centered and only wants
to think of himself that may be part of
it but it may be that he instantly dumps
into
his shame Lane because he can never be
as smart or as good as
you and so when somebody does that a
gift you can give to that person is
saying when I come to
you I trust you a B I value what you
have to say C I don't want to make this
decision all alone will you help
me and if he says no I can't do that
then you can say okay then you've got
some decisions to make if he says I feel
super scared helping you because I don't
want to mess your life up any more than
I already have but I'll give it a try
man now y'all are building something
completely
new I feel like I have done this
approach okay if you have then I think
your question is it your original
question is is a good
one are you done investing in this
relationship
and here's what here's why I want to
keep coming back to
you you want it to be
him and he may have made a bunch of
choices he may not be able to be the
partner that you need
fine but you have to make the choice of
I'm G to stop putting money in this
account I
agree so are you
done
I I feel like I have been
done what keeps you
together I guess I'm just scared for
him that makes
you do you need him to be well for you
to be
okay it's a very common thing when you
grow up in the house of people who are
recovering or people who have struggled
with addiction is to become very
codependent your success is relying on
their
success I think you just hit the nail on
the head okay the person's success you
must be most concerned about right now
is your success because only then can
you weit into the mess that is going to
be untangling a four-year relationship
that is going to be separating yourself
and allowing him to make the choices
that he as an adult can make and you
making the choices that are going to be
best for you now and in the long
run but codependency is hard hard hard
because it feels cruel to take care of
yourself in light of somebody else
making poor decisions
right right have you ever been to an
allanon
group no I have not I would strongly
strongly Rec recommend
that both for your childhood that you
grew up with and for this current
relationship because what you're going
to find is a bunch of people who have
really wrestled hard with
codependency because in many people's
lives there other
ones maybe maybe in reality or um
certainly threatened that they would die
if it's not for you you have to do X Y
and Z or I can't make it it's a heavy
burden to put on somebody 247 36
5 but I want to say something really
really firm to you
okay
okay if this relationship is not good
and I have a I have a sense in my guts
that you're hedging your bets you're not
it's it's not great is
it no in fact it's less than not great
isn't
it you're correct okay are you
safe yes I'm I'm safe
okay
um you cannot keep him
sober you cannot keep him from making
bad choices he's an adult and he gets to
make his
choices for the first time in your life
you need to take care of
Alyssa and what you're going to find is
you begin to ask Alyssa what do you
actually need and now it's coming clear
to me why that was hard for you to even
articulate you got to start asking
Alyssa what do I need what do I
want what I what makes me whole I don't
even know because right now the only
thing that feels like makes me whole is
making sure other people are
okay and there unless they're your bi
unless you're your children you don't to
be biological they can be adopted to any
unless they a
child you can't that's a scary hard
thing
hang on the line I'm going to send you a
copy of building a non-anxious life my
newest book and I want you to read it
all by
yourself and I want you to ask yourself
what about this
life that I outlined in the book could
apply to your life which parts
don't and then I want you to Google the
great Pia Melody p i a m- l o d y she's
kind of the the Godmother of
codependency this
idea and just read about her a bit and
then Google local allanon meeting and
just go once or
twice you can sit in the back and
listen and I want you to hear if any of
the other stories from the brave people
that attend those meetings sound
familiar to
you and it might be a place where you
find
peace but all of this begins with you
taking a piece of paper and a pen and
writing
down what do I actually want and what do
I
need and One Last Thing Before I Go you
mentioned I've been out of this
relationship for a long
time now I'm just worried about them let
me tell
you his body knows you've been out for a
long time his body can feel that Gap and
it wouldn't surprise me if over the last
few months things have been gotten more
and more tense have become more and more
tense cuz for a former addict for a
former somebody struggles with
addiction that sense of somebody pulling
away from them sounds every alarm they
have it wouldn't surprise me if those
alarms haven't been going off a lot in
his life which means you the load you're
carrying is become heavier and heavier
and
heavier what I mean
is if you're out you often don't do
anybody any favors by pretending by not
putting the hard conversation on the
table in fact sometimes it can be cruel
often it's cruel almost always keeping
secrets is
cruel so think a hard conversations in
your future Alysa do those things I
discussed and circle back and let me
know if I can help in any other
way